Instructor: One
really cool thing about ESLint
is that there is a fantastic
community that has built great
plugins for ESLint, and if you
take a look at this awesome
ESLint GitHub repo, you'll see
that there is a listing of all
kinds of different plugins that
you can use depending on what
type of JavaScript that you
write every single day.
Whether you're writing Angular
or Backbone, or you need to
specifically lint your Jasmine
docs, every time you write stuff
that is for a different
framework, you have a little bit
of different style rules, and
chances are that someone has
already built some sort of
linting plugin for that specific
framework. Now, something
that I use plugins for are, I
need to lint my JavaScript that
is inside of script tags in HTML
files, because that's often how
I teach. It doesn't require
extra JS files, and it doesn't
require any extra tooling to get
up and running. Second, I often
will write JavaScript inside of
markdown, which is very often
the case when I'm writing docs
or notes for a course. How do
I lint code that as not inside
of a .JS file? if you run ESLint
code right through HTML, it's
going to give you an error and
say "This ESLint doesn't
understand HTML." We need a
plugin that's going to strip
your JavaScript out of your
script tags, lint it, and tell
you what's wrong with it. Same
goes for markdown. Here we go,
let's take a look at how to use
those two specific plugins here.
I going to go into here and find
the HTML. Looks like the HTML is
actually not in here, so I'm
going to say ESLint HTML. Here
we go eslint-plugin-html. The
way that it works is you open up
your ESLint and you have a
property called plugins, and
that itself is an array, and you
simply pass the name of all of
your plugins that you want.
I've already went ahead and done
npm install eslint-plugin-html-g.
I installed it globally on my
system, and now any time I have
an ESLint file, I simply just
say I have the HTML file, give
that a save. Now if I run my
ESLint against an HTML file, it
actually tells me. It
doesn't trip up on any of my
actual HTML, but it's going to
tell me things like age is never
reassigned, use const instead.
Good. And unexpected alert. I
shouldn't be using alert. OK,
maybe I should have console.log(
age) or taken that out entirely
because it was for debugging
reasons. Now I have fixed both
of those, no errors in that one.
Let's do the same for markdown.
I'm going to go back to this
list here. I'm going to go to
the markdown linting for
JavaScript and markdown, how do
you install it, npm install
eslint-plugin-markdown. Again,
I'm going to that globally as I
want it available on all of my
projects SG eslint-plugin-
markdown. Finish installing
after about a minute or so.
How does it work? Well it looks
like you simply add markdown to
your plugins are right here, and
it looks like I would be able to
say ESLint...I could say
something like *md and that
would give me all of my
markdowns. Here we go,
unexpected var. We'll say const.
X is defined but never used. I
do something like console.log(x)
so that I make sure I actually
use it. Now rerun it and we're
off and running. By the way
this is glob pattern if you have
ever used gulp-matching or any
other sort of matching, you can
pass it a list of *.something.
You can also pass it --ext. If
you wanted to know all of the
options for ESLint, simply type
eslint--help and it will give
you a list of all of the
possible ways where you can
search for different kinds of
extensions, and pass it a
specific ESLint file. Those
are plugins. Take a look through
it and see which plugins
probably work best with your
workflow, but those are the two
that you probably will run into
at some point, and they're very
helpful to use. One little
thing I should mention that is
currently, at the time of
recording, you cannot use --fix
on HTML or markdown files. --fix
only works on pure .JS files.
Hopefully that will get fixed
soon, but don't spend any time
trying to get it to work because
it's not possible.